[Applaudissements]
il ya deux ans de cela je suis assis à
mon bureau et je sens que ma vie va
prendre un nouveau tournant je suis
ingénieur en systèmes d'information
géographique cartographes
je travaille dans un bureau d'études en
environnement les problématiques sur
lesquelles je travaille sont
passionnantes mais le temps des projets
est extrêmement long souvent plusieurs
années
de mon côté j'ai de plus en plus envie
d'immédiateté d'être en prise directe
avec l'action parallèlement à cela je
m'implique de plus en plus dans la vie
locale et notamment au sein d'une
association vélo utile qui fait la
promotion des déplacements cyclables
j'y rencontre des gens passionnés des
gens engagés qui ont envie de partager
cette expérience avec le plus grand
nombre et plus j'y pense et plus je me
dis qu'effectivement il ya dans le vélo
un outil formidable d'action et de
changement
ombre au géographe de mon côté j'observe
la ville les itinéraires les flux mais
aussi les connexions et les nôtres
tension et je me dis que effectivement
le vélo doit pouvoir apporter des
solutions nouvelles à la ville et si je
lançais une activité des plus concrètes
autour de ce fameux vélo si je devenais
coursiers à vélo
vous imaginez la tête de mes proches
quand je leur ai annoncé sa quitté un
poste d'ingénieur en cdi pour lancer une
activité de coursiers à vélo
mais tout bien pesé ma décision était
prise j'allais arrêter d'observer la
ville et entrer véritablement dans la
carte
alors point de passage obligé il fallait
rédiger ce qu'on appelle une étude de
marché
alors là encore comment voulez vous
qu'une étude de marché puisse valider un
tel projet créer un projet de coursiers
à vélo dans une ville moyenne comme
saint-brieuc 50000 habitants qui plus
est une ville connue pour sa topographie
extrêmement marqué fait de valve est
bien assise et la conclusion aurait pu
être sans doute comme l'annoncent d'un
suicide professionnel en bonne et due
forme
alors pour consolider tout ça je me suis
dit qu'il fallait que j'aille à la
rencontre de personnes qui avaient lancé
des activités similaires dans des villes
de la même taille et à ma grande
surprise on est découvert une quinzaine
en france
je me suis entretenu longuement avec eux
je suis même allé travailler avec eux
ils avaient tous des activités assez
différente mais il avait surtout un
point commun leur foi dans changement
s'était décidée j'allais devenir
coursiers à vélo mais je ne serai pas
n'importe quel coursiers à vélo je serai
vélomanes
un coursier à vélo engagé
[Applaudissements]
et un ambassadeur du changement dans les
modes de déplacements urbains
alors c'était quoi cette histoire de
coursiers à vélo qu'est ce que c'était
qu'un coursier à vélo
déjà c'était un vieux métier un métier
qu'il a été probablement de la fin du
19e siècle
à cette époque des commerçants des
artisans utilisent le vélo soit pour
distribuer leurs produits soit pour
apporter leur savoir faire au plus
proche de leurs clients en 1901 à paris
les coursiers à vélo sont si nombreux
qu'ils organisent les premières courses
de triporteurs dans les rues de la
capitale
vous allez dire ça c'était à paris mais
qu'est ce qu'il en était en province
bien j'ai appris que dans les années 30
un épicier à bord de son triporteur
sillonne la campagne briochine pour
distribuer les produits de première
nécessité il s'appelle le castor un jour
que je roulais avec mon vélo en ville
une femme m'arrête en me disant mais
vous savez monsieur moi je faisais le
même métier que vous dans les années 60
elle était livreuse pour un fleuriste et
sillonner saint brieuc et sa couronne
toute la journée
alors oui tout ceci avait bel et bien
disparu avec l'avènement de l'automobile
mais ce qui était assez passionnant
c'est que aujourd'hui grâce au vélo
cette activité retrouver une nouvelle
pertinence et l'écossé à vélo serait
implantée dans le paysage urbain
alors pourquoi tout d'abord parce qu'ils
sont rapides ils sont fluides et quel
que soit l'encombrement des voies de
circulation les embouteillages
ils n'ont pas à se soucier du
stationnement
ils peuvent garer directement aux portes
de leurs clients alors ils ont bien sûr
un handicap c'est qu'il circule sur un
territoire qui est forcément plus
restreint mais de ce handicap il tire un
grand avantage c'est que sur ce
territoire
ils circulent en continu toute la
journée et donc ils sont toujours très
proches de leur prochaine commande
il était temps pour moi d'aller au
contact de mes premiers clients
alors évidemment j'étais souvent
relativement surpris
mais il était surtout très souvent
curieux de voir en quoi ce gars ce
farfelu quelque part allez pouvoir leur
permettre d'économiser du temps d'éviter
des déplacements voire même
d'expérimenter de nouvelles perspectives
commerciales
quelque part ils avaient envie à travers
moi d'expérimenter une forme de
changement qu'il n'aurait plus
autorisées autrement et en pratiquant le
métier j'ai encore découvert d'autres
petits avantages qu'ils avaient le
coursier à vélo déjà du fait de
l'originalité de la démarche du fait
aussi de mon véhicule qui était quand
même imposant et surprenant du fait
aussi de l'effort que je produisais dans
mes déplacements et bien je donner de la
valeur aux produits que je transportais
et cette opération de transport à
travers mon activité et dans la leur
dans celle de mes clients n'étaient plus
neveu n'était plus rester un simple
maillon neutre c'est devenu un maillon
tout à fait actifs
et puis de manière plus anecdotique dans
les entreprises le coursier à vélo
confronté aux éléments et bien ils
apportent la météo forcément alors quand
il fait beau c'est génial tout le monde
ment vie et quand il fait mauvais
souvent on attend mon passage et on se
demande dans quel état je vais arriver
alors je reçois souvent des petits sms
du style alors aujourd'hui on rigole
moins
c'était un jour terrible
y'en a pas eu deux comme celui là alors
qu'est-ce que je reçois comme sms aussi
ça peut être ce jour là je crois qu'on
m'avait envoyé ce sms ont envie dit
aujourd'hui mon gars tu va ramasser et
c'était vrai c'était vrai parfois j'ai
l'impression qu'ils aimeraient être à ma
place mais pas sur la mais en tout cas
c'est une partie de leur énergie que je
m'évertue chaque jour à faire circuler
dans la ville aux produits la
satisfaction de pouvoir dire que mon
projet n'était pas une utopie
j'ai rencontré créé mon marché j'ai
réalisé des milliers de course et évitez
autant de déplacements j'ai transporter
des tonnes de plis de colis de produits
transportés des homards pour un chef
étoilé de mystérieux bouquet de roses
noires pour de non moins mystérieux
destinataire une déclaration d'amour est
une star internationale
comme quoi le changement dans
l'organisation de l'entreprise était
possible et le vélo aussi insignifiant
soit ils pouvaient contribuer à cela
c'est quand même un extraordinaire outil
de liberté ce vélo j'aimerais bien qu'on
prenne un moment ensemble pour se
remémorer un souvenir que nous avons
probablement tous en commun vous avez 5
6 ans les roues de votre petit vélo ont
été démontées le matin même et vous est
bientôt prêt à prendre votre envol la
main d'un de vos parents qui est encore
votre selle et sans même que vous vous
en soyez rendu compte la main et menthe
vous aura libéré et vous serez en cet
état d'équilibré d'apesanteur
si propre à la bicyclette et que les
scientifiques peinent encore un petit
peu aujourd'hui a expliqué en tout cas
vous êtes en train de chevaucher le
premier outil qui va vous permettre
d'aller au delà du regard de vos parents
et d'explorer votre petit monde de plus
en plus loin d'explorer un espace vécu
un espace perçu un espace qui ne se
comptent pas simplement km un espace qui
se comptent surtout à l'intensité des
expériences sensorielles et sociales que
vous allez pouvoir y vivre à vélo ce
sont tous les sens qui sont en éveil
c'est presque de la réalité augmentée je
vous emmène pour quelques tours de roues
à vélo déjà c'est la vision
vous avez une vision qui est tout à fait
panoramique d'autant plus panoramique
que vous êtes vraiment très haut quand
vous êtes assis sur votre selle en fait
avec cette vision panoramique vous
observez quoi vous observez le champ
lointain celui qui vous indiquent le cap
à suivre mais aussi les dangers à éviter
vous êtes quasiment en train de dérouler
un travelling sur la ville surtout à
vélo c'est le champ proche le champ
proche sont sans aucun angle mort le
champ proche qui va laisser place à
toutes ces petites et aux observations
qui vont donner la saveur à vos
déplacements à vélo forcément c'est
aussi la vitesse avez vous déjà ressenti
la vitesse avec autant d'intensité que
lorsque le nez langue ils ont les
cheveux au vent ça je ne peux pas trop
le faire vous baissez la tête pour
accélérer encore un peu plus fort et oui
à vélo en fait vous aller relativement
vite à vélo vous vous déplacez entre 15
et 20 km heure de moyenne
un véhicule motorisé une voiture déplace
plutôt en ville à 14 kilomètres heure
mais vous avez surtout un grand avantage
c'est que vous pouvez vous permettre de
ralentir ralentir pour croiser un regard
voire même vous payer le luxe de vous
arrêter pour engager une conversation et
c'est bien ça l'objet de la ville créer
de l'interaction humaine à vélo vous
cumulez la vitesse de l'automobile à la
liberté du piéton à vélo lorsque vous
vous déplacez c'est aussi reconnecter
avec les odeurs de la ville les
mauvaises commes les bonnes en passant
près d'une boulangerie ou d'une
torréfaction je sais pas si je devrais
vous dire mais moi une de mes auteurs
préférés c'est l'odeur des camions
poubelles
c'est aussi reprendre conscience des
sons les sons de la ville en passant du
brouhaha d'un embouteillage au calme
paisible d'une petite ruelle entendre à
nouveau le chant des oiseaux ou le cri
des enfants aux abords d'une cour
d'école
en tout cas lorsque vous roulez à vélo
vous êtes pleinement dans votre
environnement vous êtes pleinement dans
l'environnement et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait probablement une expérience unique
alors vous dit ce gars il est bien
gentil il est totalement passionné il un
petit peu dans son délire
comment voulez vous qu'ils nous donnent
envie nous les les gens un peu plus
normaux alors je vais vous parler d'une
expérience que j'ai eu la chance de
vivre dans le cadre de mes activités
associatives il ya quelques mois nous
avions choisi de nous adresser un public
nous connaissions assez peu en tout cas
beaucoup moins c'était le public des
salariés et nous voulions faire la
démonstration que les déplacements
domicile travail à vélo était faisable
l'objectif c'était de créer un événement
qui s'est matérialisé sous la forme d'un
challenge
un challenge qui à dieu qui buvaient
devait durer cinq jours et durant cinq
jours ses cinq jours nous voulions faire
rouler un maximum de gens ensemble
le premier objectif pour nous c'était de
convaincre les chefs d'entreprise que ça
avait de l'intérêt pour eux et
aujourd'hui les études le prouvent des
salariés qui se déplace à vélo
ce sont des salariés qui sont mieux
oxygénés qui sont souvent en meilleure
santé et probablement un peu plus
heureux pour les salariés l'objectif
était de leur montrer qu'ils en étaient
capables
ils n'habitaient pas forcément si loin
que ça de leur lieu de travail et qu'ils
pouvaient franchir des distances
relativement importante avec leur vélo
c'est aussi leur dire qu'ils allaient
pouvoir vivre une expérience collective
parce que c'était aussi ça l'enjeu et le
petit déclencheur du challenge
et en fait en allant rencontrer ces gens
dans le cadre des ateliers qu'on a pu
mener chez eux on s'est rendu compte
manière assez bête est assez dommage
mais aussi assez intéressante c'était
que grand nombre de ces personnes ne
pratiquait plus le vélo simplement parce
qu'ils ne se l'autorisé pas et
l'opération extrêmement bien marché
puisque ils ont été près de 300 à
participer et à rouler ensemble ensemble
durant ces cinq jours
l'opération a tellement bien fonctionné
qu'ils ont roulé l'équivalent de la
distance de saint brieuc à pékin voire
même un peu plus puisque ils ont roulé
9300 qu'il km cumulés
c'est assez inespéré pour une telle
opération sachant qu'on est bien
d'accord qu'à saint brieuc on nous
disait qu'on pouvait pas faire de vélo
et un jour que je passais d'entreprise
en entreprise pour voir le bon
déroulement de l'opération
je croise une femme qui me dit en fait
durant ces cinq jours je me suis sentie
vivante
j'ai eu un temps d'arrêt je me suis dit
que effectivement il y avait un enjeu
extraordinaire à faire découvrir ses
modes de déplacement à un maximum de
gens aujourd'hui je continue à
développer mon activité rencontrer des
entrepreneurs et à essayer de les
convaincre de me faire confiance je
continuais également une activité
associative plus que jamais mais
j'espère surtout vous vous avoir donné
envie de vous remettre en selle parce
que comme le dit l'expression le vélo ça
ne s'oublie pas
[Applaudissements]